[Music]
hi i'm nick edwards i've been at the
court for seven years i'm from the
netherlands i have two kids and in my
spare time i like to play tennis and go
jogging
i worked for about
six seven years
in the private sector before joining the
court in the chemicals and the
pharmaceutical industries i have a
career where i could do different things
and at the courts
i was told and it's true that you can
explore really very different areas and
i like that very much so
next year i'll be doing something
completely different that i was doing
this year
i've been working on
covid the eu's response to kovid
since mid 2020
and i'm now a task leader on the audit
on the eu's procurement of covid
vaccines
i think you need some mathematical
literacy
but it is so much more than that and
it's not enough to just be good at maths
it's it's about analysis it's about
policies it's about sometimes politics
as well uh
it's it's about
you know building a picture and telling
a story
i mean most of our work of course is
office based
and computer-based and that's normal we
do get to travel a bit as well which
you know which is and it's good to get
out of the office
it's still on a human scale i think
and that's something i appreciate you
know you're not just a number they they
know who you are
i encourage them very strongly to apply
i think it's a it's a great place to
work it's a great place to start your
career
you can explore different policy areas
different types of audit that you like